hey zoey oh it's wasabi you need coffee
how are you
i'm good so good to see you it's been so
long last time i saw you was at tiff and
i think that was like what five years
ago i don't know but i absolutely adore
you you are such a badass and to see you
with our canadian boy ryan reynolds
gamora and deadpool together i mean is
he like the nicest guy you've ever
worked with
um he's right on top yeah he's in the
top five for sure top top three top two
maybe yeah
um he's he's amazing he is professional
he is committed he is witty
um he's meticulous it was it was really
inspiring
was he annoying at all
no
no
i think that i think that we must have
been
all annoying we were shooting in the
middle of the pandemic where everybody's
you know sentences are super heightened
and and um and it was all about just
comfort and safety
and making sure they were all you know
okay
and but when the cameras would roll
that's when i guess we gave ourselves a
permission to just lower our guards a
little bit
and allow these characters to to sort of
seep out of us and he is just the master
of improvisation like he just
comes out with those zingers and those
one-liners right when you least expect
them so it's hard to keep a straight
face in the take
you know what i love this film too
because it's really a love letter to
mothers out there and it's such a
celebratory moment and also makes you
think about moments you want to go back
to and
revisit in your life and i thought about
it i would love to see my grandpa again
i mean what's a moment for you would
love to go back to
oh my god i would love to see my dad you
know i lost my dad when i was nine years
old so i would love to sort of spend the
last christmas with him all over again
because it was so great
and you know i was looking at your
instagram and you did the beyonce drop
tick-tock trend
all dressed in gamora i mean are you on
tick tock because i can't find you on
tick tock and are you like into these
trends no no no i don't know how to use
tick tock i'm not on tick tock i i'm
finally
feeling comfortable in instagram right
when instagram is about to go out you
know
i'm i'm a late bloomer with technology
and and i don't take pride in it i'm
actually pretty ashamed to admit it
but because i've always been the kind of
person that if something isn't broken i
don't want to fix it i don't need a new
phone if my phone is still working and
it hasn't broken down but that means
that i miss you know all the nuances of
the newer technology and um that's okay
though um i'm having a great deal of fun
sort of sharing aspects of my life that
i'm comfortable sharing um in hopes of
like just creating some kind of
relatability with with people out there
that are struggling with their new
year's resolutions that want to get back
to feeling healthier especially after
the pandemic it's been really hard i
think having a laugh at yourself really
it inspires others to laugh at
themselves and that's a part of me that
i've i don't think i've shared enough
with people
um i am very quirky i'm very geeky i'm
very clumsy
it takes me seven tries to get something
right
but i am not a quitter so i you know i i
wanted to share that about myself and
then it turns out that there's so many
people like me i'm not the special one
there's nothing special about me and um
and that's felt really great yeah the
older we get the more comfortable we get
right
oh my god you start caring less about
all the arbitrary things just have a lot
of fun you are absolutely amazing
congratulations on linus as well and you
just you're just kick ass love you thank
you so much